one of the biggest problem globally is
that there's a lack of financial
education this is true in the united
states and also internationally what we
have seen is that the wealth inequality
gap it's not actually a wealth-driven
problem it's an education-driven problem
because of inflationary nature of money
and especially high inflation that's
ravaging the world all over country by
country by country we've seen the people
who understand how that works and why
holding investable assets is important
they've been getting richer but the
bottom half of the global population
especially in the united states the
people who don't understand that they
simply continue to try to save their way
to financial security and that is a
major problem but don't take my word for
it i saw this recent reddit post from
somebody in ireland a place that usually
doesn't get that much coverage and they
explicitly called out this very problem
here's what they said i'm irish and not
many people over here are familiar with
cryptocurrency and the potential that it
brings i read this ignorant and
tone-deaf article this morning and i was
probably displaying visible anger
ireland like many places is suffering
from inflation and rising housing prices
comments such as why would you swap your
nice steady euros left me perplexed are
these people completely out of touch
with the reality that the average person
is living in nothing is mentioned about
the long-term goal of these
cryptocurrencies i am well and truly
flabbergasted that our national news
provider would publish such an article
the real shame is that many in ireland
would only use rte as their source of
information and this is the first thing
that they would have read about crypto
and they will run a million miles away
from it now of course the mainstream
media they may not be in touch with the
average person they may not understand
how bad inflation is impacting them they
may not understand that the average
person continues to fall further and
further behind but they also don't
understand bitcoin or cryptocurrencies
they don't understand the technology
they don't understand the economic
impact it can have on a person who
decides to be responsible to simply
dollar cost average not to speculate but
to simply use it as a savings technology
but that is why it is so important for
every one of us myself and you who's
watching this to continue to help
educate to spread the word to make sure
that people around the world understand
what this technology can do help them
understand how money works help them
understand what inflation does help them
explain why saving in an asset that
continues to lose purchasing power may
not be a smart financial decision the
mainstream media is going to continue to
do what they do we can sit here and we
can complain about it or we can simply
get to work and try to compete in the
marketplace and say to ourselves we have
the knowledge now all we have to do is
share it this person in ireland they get
it they realize that the information
that's being spread may not be accurate
and so ultimately they myself and you we
simply just have to start to speak up
spread the word and then the technology
will get the global adoption that it
deserves